this is a production of cornell
university
hi my name is esther pullen i graduated
in 2004 with a plant science degree from
cornell
and when i was in high school and
college i
didn't really know if i could do
anything with a degree in agriculture
but i knew i loved working outdoors i
enjoyed plants
i loved my classes in agriculture when i
was at cornell
and i wanted to do something that would
make a difference that really meant
something
and what i've found in my year since i
graduated
is that agriculture is the foundation
for so many things that go on in the
world today
from food to fiber to energy
all of these things have a basis in
agriculture and it touches the lives of
everyone in the world and one of the
things that i've also found is that i'm
working for a number of different
companies in the produce industry and
seeing people from across
the world of agriculture is that there
are many jobs
in agriculture there are companies who
are looking for
motivated qualified individuals who have
passion
and experience in agriculture so that
they can
make wonderful things happen so if you
are interested in making a difference
and traveling the world seeing many new
things
then a plant sciences degree from
cornell would be a great way to start
that
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu